mais ça
donc ensemble nous allons faire un
atelier de fabrication de chocolat à la
fleur de sel 2 5
m
donc on a voulu justement m c'est la tv
en place pour d'une part valoriser la
fleur du synthé aussi ap de l'om le
chocolat
est une pierre deux coups bien sûr ce
côté où il faut expliquer comment projet
du sel à la pointe au sel et aussi la
transformation lieu de la fève de cacao
chocolat
oui du cacaoyer c'est là
mais
le chocolat de chocolat noir et et et
amer on apprend à faire d'eux les
chocolats et on ne refait on a fait
fondre le chocolat on a nous le st beck
le chocolat se fait avec du sel de la
fleur de sel et club que le chocolat
c'est fait avec beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup des cycles sont des choses
demain qui côtoie tous les jours mais
donc savent pas forcément bien commencé
fabriquer tous qui en amont et je pense
que c'est vraiment très intéressant qui
travaille dessus
c'est vraiment un intérêt pédagogique en
même temps c'est lui dis que c'est
vraiment intéressant pour les enfants on
nous a fait la proposition via le
département donc du coup ben moi dès que
j'ai vu ça m'a tout de suite intéressé
parce que jamais mise en fait
personnellement
eh ben j'ai accepté et puis je me suis
inscrit
narbonne je suis positivement monde
ap